todas las especies aprenden investigando
de pequeño así como probablemente muchos
de los que estamos acá me gustaba
desarmar cosas el problema era que
muchas veces no podía volver a armar las
es así que en una oportunidad junto a mi
primo cuando tenía 7 años desarmamos un
robot como este robot era mío me quedé
con la parte más preciada que era la
cabeza y saben por qué porque en esta
cabeza había una luz
al desmantelar este pobre juguete vi que
cayeron dos cables de la cabeza y mi
razonamiento de niño al no tener pilas
en ese momento me hizo pensar que podía
podría utilizar estos cables como un
enchufe de cualquier electrodoméstico y
conectarlo al tomacorriente para
tenerlos en la oscuridad fui cuando esta
brillante idea o comentarle a mi papá
que en ese entonces se desempeñaba como
electrónico y él me dio una clase
magistral de por qué no tenía que
hacerlo
pero bueno ya se imaginarán lo que
ocurrió
al conectar estos cables al
tomacorriente la cabeza del robot
explotó gracias a dios no me pasó nada
pero hubo un problema se bajó el
automático que alimentaba de
electricidad a nuestra casa dejándonos
todo un día sin suministro eléctrico
con esta experiencia aprendí tres cosas
la primera que mi papá tenía razón
la segunda que mi hipótesis fue echada
por tierra completamente y la tercera es
que sale bastante claro que vengan de la
compañía de electricidad arreglar un
problema de este tipo
al seguir creciendo este esta mente
inquieta y curiosa siguió aumentando y
sigue complementando actualmente mi
desempeño profesional actualmente
trabajo como fue un audiólogo en una
escuela básica
principalmente enfocado en el desarrollo
y en la intervención de la lectura y de
sus trastornos asociados
es así que trabajando en esta área me di
cuenta de dos grandes problemas el
primero es que hay muchos estudiantes
que no aprenden a leer con las
metodologías tradicionales en relación a
este punto cree un programa de
estimulación en base a lo que la
literatura científica refiere como
idóneo para estos casos y este programa
comenzaba cuando los niños están
ingresando a la escuela cuando tienen
cuatro años y dura hasta alrededor de
los siete años
los resultados preliminares de esta
investigación arrojan como resultado que
aquellos estudiantes que recibieron el
programa completo de estimulación leen
en promedio 17 palabras más por minutos
que aquellos que no quizás para algunos
no puede ser tanto pero si tomamos esta
cifra y hacemos un ejercicio simple de
lectura de 10 minutos
tendríamos que aquellos estudiantes que
no recibieron el programa completo
serían en promedio 170 palabras menos
ahora si hacemos un ejercicio un poquito
más generoso y acá a cada estudiante lo
hacemos leer 33 minutos diarios durante
un mes tendríamos que aquellos
estudiantes que no recibieron el
programa estimulación leerían en
promedio 17.000 palabras menos
ahora si tomamos esta cifra y la
extendemos hacia un año 12 meses
tendríamos que los estudiantes que no
recibieron el programa completo leerían
en promedio 204 mil palabras menos lo
que para mí es una cifra significativa
el segundo problema que encontré era que
si los estudiantes cuando están
comenzando a leer presentan dificultades
en la lectura que no son intervenidas de
manera temprana y de la manera correcta
estas dificultades iban a ir aumentando
a medida que el niño debe ir creciendo y
es así que les voy a presentar el caso
de una niña
a esta niña en la evaluación inicial le
dije la siguiente oración que ella tenía
que copiar
juanito se escondió debajo de la cama
para que no lo pillara su mamá y nuestra
amiga escribió esto
si se dan cuenta presenta muchos errores
en la escritura sustituye mucho las
vocales y principalmente los cambios por
la letra ahora
quizás para algunos puede decir que está
estudiante tiene entre 6 7 años primer o
segundo año básico recién
familiarizándose con la lectura pero
esta niña tenía 11 años
e iba en sexto año básico
al mes de intervención trabajando con un
gran compromiso el estudiante y lo que
la literatura refiere como idóneo en
estos casos así se encontraba si se dan
cuenta ya comete menos errores y ya
sustituye menos la letra o
y casi a los 3 meses de intervención
nuestra amiga escribía de esta manera
si se dan cuenta ya prácticamente no
comete errores mejoró de una manera
increíble su grafía además de su
velocidad lectora su rendimiento
académico
su autoestima y lo que más la tenía
contenta era que ahora podía estudiar
desde sus cuadernos porque ahora se
entendía la letra
qué es lo curioso el anecdótico de este
caso que según investigaciones entre el
10 y el 20 por ciento de la población
mundial en mayor o menor grado tiene
trastornos de la lectura así que
probablemente entre nosotros haya muchos
infiltrados
si se habrán dado cuenta
esta mente curiosa inquieta
sigue trabajando
y en base a eso empecé a investigar ya
trabajar en relación al juego cognitivo
el juego cognitivo es una actividad que
se realiza antes de una actividad
cognitiva más demandante como estudiar
asistir a clase hacer una prueba y lo
que hace es preparar el cerebro ponerlo
en alerta para que sea mucho más
receptivo y en base a eso ahora no se
podía invitar a jugar vamos a hacer dos
equipos todos ustedes contra mí
en este juego ustedes van a tener dos
vidas pero si se equivocan uno del
equipo todo el equipo pierde la vida
las reglas de juego son las siguientes
cuando digo 1 ustedes aplauden dos veces
uno
uno excelente cuando digo dos no
aplauden 2
no aplauden 2
2 muy bien y cuando diga 3 aplauden una
vez 3
[Aplausos]
3 excelente ahora vamos a comenzar pero
les voy a pedir que cierre los ojos por
favor
necesito que estén muy concentrados
fuerte y claro 2
lamentablemente hubo muchos que
aplaudieron así que perdieron su primera
vida pero no se preocupen que les queda
la siguiente nuevamente necesito que
cierren los ojos
para sí muy concentrados muy
concentrados fuerte y claro 2
lamentablemente perdieron su última vida
y les gané aplauso para ustedes
[Aplausos]
si se dan cuenta este fue un ejercicio
simple de realizar
y que aparte de mejorar el clima en una
sala de clases
y más que ganar o perder el objetivo era
otro con este ejercicio ustedes
trabajaron atención memoria seguimiento
de instrucciones inhibición o bloqueo de
aquellas respuestas que no correspondían
y el trabajo en equipo
todo lo que les he venido comentando lo
he venido trabajando desde el año 2013
ya tributaba en esto
la creación de uno de los primeros
departamentos de investigación insertos
en una escuela básica siendo pioneros a
nivel nacional y probablemente también a
nivel latinoamericano
el objetivo este departamento es poder
complementar o mejorar las prácticas
docentes y clínicas de todas los
profesionales y técnicos que trabajan en
la escuela
en este departamento aparte de contar
con el apoyo completo del equipo
directivo del cuerpo docente asistente
de la educación contamos con un horario
protegido para reunirnos a investigar y
este departamento está acá en la región
de la araucanía a casi 700 kilómetros de
santiago específicamente en la comuna
del con
qué es lo más anecdótico o lo más
importante de esto que según el
ministerio de educación en chile existen
8 mil 334
escuelas básicas por tanto las
posibilidades de replicar esta
experiencia literalmente son miles
pero a pesar de todo lo que les he
nombrado
surge un interrogante
para hay que investigar la investigación
nos abre un mundo totalmente nuevo en el
cual nos permite dotar de evidencia
científica cada acto o actividad que se
realice para así optimizar los procesos
de enseñanza-aprendizaje de nuestros
estudiantes asimismo la investigación te
permite sistematizar aquellas
experiencias exitosas para que puedan
ser replicadas con posterioridad y
finalmente el estar investigando te
mantiene en un constante desafío de ir
actualizando sus prácticas cotidianas
muchas veces las instituciones se quejan
por la falta de recursos o insumos pero
se les olvida algo importante que la
principal materia prima está aquí en
nuestro cerebro por tanto la invitación
es que nunca dejen de investigar que no
dejen que su mente inquieta y curiosa se
duerma que sistematicen aquellas
experiencias exitosas ya fin de cuentas
hay que hacían una gente real de cambio
propositivo en cada uno de los lugares
los que se desempeñen muchas gracias
[Aplausos]